[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 9 juillet bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres de cette édition c'est
le dispositif d'éducation musicale et
orchestrale à vocation sociale les
orchestres demos des yvelines ont dû
s'arrêter pendant le confinement à
chanteloup-les-vignes un stage d'été est
organisée en ce moment pour permettre
aux enfants de se retrouver avant les
vacances
du changement à la direction du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
polaire ni ted va quitter la structure
dont il est à la tête depuis 2014
il sera remplacé par son bras droit
philippe pilate aux interviews à suivre
et puis connaissez-vous le bir tourisme
une manière de découvrir le territoire
par le travail du houblon avec
modération bien sûr
à la fin de ce journal découverte de ce
parcours brassicole dans le département
et direction chanteloup les vignes pour
débuter des enfants participant au
projet et demos ont pu se retrouver pour
un stage d'été cette semaine pour rappel
ce dispositif vise à démocratiser la
pratique de la musique en orchestre
l'occasion pour ces jeunes musiciens de
se réapproprier leur instrument le
reportage doré lyons ils ne s'étaient
pas revus depuis plusieurs mois ces
enfants âgés entre 7 et 10 ans font tous
partie de leurs quatre demos ce
dispositif d'éducation musicale et
orchestrale à vocation sociale est
financé notamment par le département des
yvelines
coordonné par la philharmonie de paris
il existe depuis 2000 16 h encollées
ligne l'idée c'est que c'est des enfants
qu'on jamais touché à la musique et qui
par ce biais de ce dispositif
et là ils vont pouvoir continuer
éventuellement en faire parce qu'au bout
des trois ans si jamais ils ont continué
et ils ont
u de l'appétence pour cette pratique
l'instrument est offert les enfants
suivent quatre heures de cours par
semaine est des cours qui ont dû être
suspendues en raison du confinement des
parents m'ont dit tout simplement qu'ils
n'étaient pas eux mêmes musiciens
donc c'est vrai que c'est très compliqué
en fait de pouvoir soutenir son enfant
sur un instrument qu'on a pas qu'on n'a
pas forcément fait notamment les cuivres
trompette trombone ou encore euphonium
ce stage d'été permet à ces jeunes
mélomanes de reprendre leurs instruments
en main là c'est un peu
récapitulatif de tout ce qu'on a appris
depuis le début de l'année que là on
essaie de remettre à niveau tout ce
qu'on avait appris
[Musique]
des fois je n'arrive pas à faire des
sons du coup c'est difficile pour moi
des fois on se trompe mais on commence
pas très rares à chanteloup les vignes
les ateliers reprendront en septembre
au total sept communes participent au
projet demos dans les yvelines le point
à présent sur l'épidémie de coronavirus
dans le département la légère hausse du
nombre d'hospitalisations dans les
yvelines se confirme un patient
supplémentaire a été enregistré entre
mardi et mercredi 360 était hospitalisé
sur le territoire aux derniers chiffres
communiqués 20 sont toujours en
réanimation depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire 519 personnes sont mortes à
l'hôpital des suites de lakovic 19 2200
une personne sont revenus à domicile
guéri d'une forme grave de la maladie
santé toujours avec la fondation anne de
gaulle qui va bientôt s'implanter à
montigny le bretonneux c'est prévu pour
fin 2022 est déjà présente à versailles
et milon-la-chapelle l'association va
ouvrir un foyer avec 100 places
d'hébergement pour les personnes
déficientes mentales ainsi avec un
living lab une plate forme pour
permettre les rencontres entre
chercheurs et résidente à la fondation
anne de gaulle du nom de la fille du
général atteintes de trisomie 21 est
spécialisé dans la déficience
intellectuelle un mode économie avec
l'entreprise plaisir fruité à trappes
qui a souffert pendant le confinement
spécialisé dans la vente de fruits et
légumes la société d'une trentaine
d'employés a réussi cependant à
s'adapter en ciblant une nouvelle
clientèle les précisions dans ce sujet
du go kitson et patrick jacques de
dixmude la crise sanitaire du colis de
19 a eu un impact conséquent sur cette
entreprise trappistes plaisir fruité a
vu son chiffre d'affaires baisser de
moitié pendant cette période
avant la crise la firme vendait environ
12 tonnes de fruits et de légumes par
semaine avec notamment des livraisons
destinées aux professionnels ont là une
baisse du chiffre d'affaires
effectivement puisque les entreprises
aujourd'hui nous sur la partie
livraison à l'entreprise ont le plus de
1000 entreprises toutes les semaines en
fruits dans leurs locaux et
donc on a une baisse de 100 % on a tout
perdu pendant le confinement ou là il ya
des entreprises qui reprennent
progressivement mais encore l'été donc
on va dire il ya les entreprises
favorisent encore beaucoup le
télétravail pour rebondir et préserver
la trentaine d'emplois du site
l'entreprise a dû se diversifier pendant
la période de confinement en s'adaptant
notamment aux demandes de leurs nouveaux
clients et en renouvelant leur packaging
là où on s'est aussi améliorée c'est que
du coup maintenant on est en livraison
par le biais de des smartphones donc il
ya on arrive à avoir une traçabilité sur
la livraison sans contact avec la
clientèle puisque maintenant la preuve
de livraison c'est une photo aujourd'hui
l'entreprise espère encore booster son
activité après cette période difficile
plaisir fruité devrait s'étendre en
septembre prochain
en ouvrant une nouvelle boutique à
versailles il ya le lieu aurait pu
accueillir le nouveau centre
d'entraînement du paris saint-germain un
projet finalement abandonné est le
domaine de grignon est en vente un
processus qui avance puisque les
candidats au rachat avaient jusqu'au 7
juillet pour se faire connaître
un site de 310 hectares qui accueille
actuellement l'école agroparistech qui
va partir à l'horizon 2022
l'intercommunalité coeur divine
l'association grignon 2000 ou encore le
conseil départemental sont intéressés
par le domaine est les candidats retenus
seront dévoilés en septembre et du
changement à venir du côté du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
son directeur paul hermitage va quitter
la fonction de directeur qu'il assure
depuis 2014 il sera remplacé dans les
prochains jours par son bras droit
philippa pilato est les deux hommes ont
notamment connu l'organisation de la
ryder cup 2018 sur place interview
michael et demi d'euros les images
d'aurélie ans nous sommes au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines à
mes côtés à pau l'ermitage qui est le
directeur du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et philippe
pilato qui est le chef des opérations du
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines mais il va y avoir du
changement c'est bien ça messieurs c'est
ça dans 72 heures 72 heures voilà on va
on va passer les codes nucléaires les
codes nucléaires avant passé de droite à
gauche et
voilà je vais donner à philippe les clés
de la maison alors pourquoi vous quittez
le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines paul après si
je me trompe pas six années ici vous
êtes arrivé en le 1er septembre 2014
c'est ça ce sera exactement six ans un
petit peu plus parce que j'ai j'ai quand
même commencé à apprendre le bébé en
main à partir de juin juillet 2014
pourquoi je pars parce que j'ai coché à
peu près toutes les cases qui était sur
sûrement job description sur la fiche de
mission qu'on m'avait donné à l'époque
et je suis un homme qui était réellement
de toute façon en mouvement qui a besoin
de mission et il est temps de passer la
main à quelqu'un d'autre pour amener le
groupe national dans une nouvelle ère
philippe pilate os que le départ de paul
est un mythe edge vous surprend ou pas
vous avez peut-être un petit peu discuté
avant me surprend bah oui et non sur le
côté on va dire humains affectif
j'aurais bien évidemment voulu continuer
l'aventuré avec paul parce qu'on a on a
travaillé en étroite collaboration
depuis maintenant six ans on a fait
beaucoup de choses ensemble m'a appris
beaucoup de choses également et
voilà une nouvelle vision et ce qu'on a
réussi à mettre en place et voilà par
rapport à ce qui nous a dit à son
arrivée après maintenant comme il l'a
dit paul que c'est un jeu c'est que
c'est un homme j'ai appris à le
connaître et je sais que c'est un homme
de challenge et je sais que voilà il a
il fallait il fallait qui rebondit sur
autre chose et je pense que c'est une
bonne chance une belle opportunité pour
lui par rapport à par rapport à son
futur son futur professionnel de votre
futur professionnel justement paul oui
ça sera quoi
alors je reste dans le golfe je reste en
france je reste
pas loin paris on se débarrasse pas
aussi facilement que ça je vais
rejoindre un groupe français au niveau
de leurs opérations pour aider aussi
cette entreprise là en présence d'une
nouvelle ère également qui a envie de
moderniser que de changer parmi les
moments forts de votre carrière ici au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines il ya eu
forcément pour les open de france mais
la ryder cup 2018 une première ici en
france forcément c'est votre plus beau
souvenir ici au golf national
alors non c'est parle c'est pas votre
plus beau souvenir non c'est pas le plus
beau souvenir parce que c'est
dès que je suis arrivé on m'a fixé
d'autres objectifs et m'ont plu
beau souvenir c'est ce qu'on a atteint
sur un plan humain c'est clair c'est la
ryder cup était positionné dans comment
dire dans tous les challenges qu'il y
avait évidemment c'était important mais
ça aurait été un désastre si on n'avait
pas eu une équipe à la hauteur et ça
aurait été encore plus désastreux si on
n'avait pas une prestation pour les
clients à la hauteur de ce qu'ils
imaginent d'un site de rise up blanc
c'est tout ça autour qui est le plus je
dire ouais le plus excitant pour nous la
ryder cup bien sûr on à y participer
de tous les jours
parce que multilingue on était impliqué
dans l'organisation même pendant
l'événement et c'est un rêve mais j'ai
pu résister
presque une dizaine d'autos ryder cup
dans ma vie en angleterre aux etats unis
un peu partout en tant que fan et je l'
ai vécu à l'intérieur un peu comme ça
aussi
donc c'est tout autour c'est les deux
années avant surtout l'accélération
envers l'événement et puis les deux
années avant sa de de travailler avec
des personnes qui avaient envie qu'ils
avaient vraiment envie de faire une
réussite de la ryder cup filly pilato
vous vous aurez également d'autres
objectifs
il ya notamment les jo 2000 24 qui sont
organisées ici vous avez ouvre également
cette ryder cup 2018 en france
forcément c'est un challenge excitant
pour vous bah oui jeux olympiques ça va
être formidable
c'est vrai que d'organiser c'était
preuve qu'il en rêvait d'un dindon va
dire d'un sportif et les preuves qu'on
souhaitait à laquelle on souhaite
participer c'est quand même formidable
mais je le placerais aussi également un
peu comme la ryder cup sur comment on a
pu en parler avec paul ryder cup c'est
une étape
voilà et notre notre travail c'est est
de préparer au mieux d'être le les plus
près possible pour pour accueillir et
faire en sorte à ce que c'était que
cette étape soit bien vécue par les
collaborateurs soient bien vécu bien
nouvel an par le public et les jo je
pense qu'on va l'aborder exactement de
la même façon une étape dans la vie
d'ailleurs le championnat du monde
amateur championnat d'europe jeux
olympiques d open de france sont tout un
tas des tables sur lesquelles il faut
qu'on soit à la hauteur et sur lesquels
on doit mobiliser les équipes oui est ce
que vous êtes un petit peu de différence
sur votre manière de penser
le golf national ou est ce que vous êtes
d'accord à peu près surtout philippe
elain une histoire qui est différente
de la mienne philippe est ici depuis 26
ans à chaque fois que 10 21 ans j'ai
peur de le blesser parce que ça fait
longtemps et puis 25 ans et puis en plus
25 ans je ne suis pas donc depuis 26 ans
philippe est là felipe est un est un
comment dire extrêmement fidèle loyal à
la fédération française de golf
moi aussi pendant la période dans
laquelle j'étais et si c'est pas ça que
je veux dire mais on n'a pas la même
histoire moi je suis arrivé à un moment
où il y avait un besoin et il y avait
une étape à franchir il y avait besoin
peut-être d'amener une ressource
extérieure aujourd'hui c'est pas que ça
roule parce qu'il y aura toujours
quelque chose qui arrive au golf
national toujours il ya plein tous les
jours il ya quelque chose qui arrive
aujourd'hui à l'équipe de france qui
s'entraîne
c'est sans fin mais on est arrivé 1
comment dire un organisation qui est pas
mal optimisé avec de bonnes équipes de
bonnes personnes sur lequel philippe
peut compter c'est à dire qu'on a créé
cette équipe ensemble c'est un peu plus
c'est pas facile ce ne sera jamais
facile mais c'est un peu plus stable
dernière question qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter philippe il a tôt vous
allez bientôt commencer qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter de faire aussi bien
que paul voilà de faire aussi mieux et
faire mieux voilà mon objectif c'est de
faire mieux c'est de le battre est donc
donc donc voilà non mais c'est ça c'est
de réussir toujours bienvenu au golf
national pour une partie l'avant et on
va lui faire une carte de membre membre
honoraire à vie
maintenant oui c'est vrai c'est de faire
c'est de faire voilà aussi bien voire
mieux que ce qu'on a fait ces six
dernières années de porter le golf
national la wii doit-être siro sommet au
sommet de la pyramide du golf en france
et voilà est de faire en sorte que tous
les événements qui seront les prochains
des nôtres on les mène les mène à bien
par l'ermitage
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter à
vous aussi bas la même chose que je vous
souhaite beaucoup beaucoup de succès et
d'être heureux et ça ça ne manquera pas
merci à tous les deux merci pour cette
interview et on vous souhaite beaucoup
de courage et bonne chance pour vos
nouvelles fonctions merci beaucoup
parlons boxe à présent ahmed el
moussaoui retourne au combat le boxeur
originaire de la verrière va affronter
ce samedi 11 juillet l'allemand sergei
votre seul le combat est programmée à
düsseldorf dans un drive in en plein air
et les blinois est le favori de ce match
il totalise 32 victoires trois défaites
et un nul
son adversaire de 30 ans affiche un
bilan de 14 victoires quatre défaites et
un nul mais attention il aura
al'avantage de boxer à domicile
elle est labellisée ville d'art et
d'histoire depuis le début du mois
rambouillet propose des visites traitant
de différents thèmes les rambolitains
peuvent notamment découvrir en ce moment
leur commune sous l'occupation est le
reportage de mathilde et demi déambuler
dans la ville pour découvrir rambouillet
sous l'occupation
c'est le thème des visites de cette
ville d'art et d'histoire le lieu de
départ le palais du roi de rome un lieu
emblématique pour commencer la visite
qui dure environ 1h30 on connaît jamais
vraiment complètement sa ville et donc
ça peut permettre de
de découvrir des nouveaux endroits et
connaître des événements qui se sont
produits sur ce rambouillet des cas une
visite nouvelles sur c'est sur ces
thèmes
des histoires de rambouillet histoire
très riche de rambouillet des cas une
visite nouvelle qui proposait on essaye
de participer
direction l'église saint lubin rue
gambetta pour ce groupe de neuf curieux
une visite pleine d'anecdotes qui permet
au robot lee temps de se familiariser
avec leur histoire et faire leur devoir
de mémoire
cette première visite en fait allé un
peu solide parce que c'est la première
fois qu'on l'a fait donc j'espère qu'à
plaira et en fait c'est voir rambouillet
sous un autre angle c'est le plus
quasiment le plus contemporain aussi si
je puis dire début xxème siècle voilà
rambouillet cette période de
l'occupation qu'est ce qui s'est passé
comment rambouillet était marqué et
surtout la période de la libération même
si elle s'appelle rambouillet sous
l'occupation
parce que rambouillet a été témoin en
fait d'un événement hors du commun au
niveau local mais aussi qu'ils
rejoignent l'histoire nationale et donc
c'est vraiment passionnant
pendant toute la visite le groupe
s'arrêtera devant le bureau de poste
l'école primaire gambetta une villa
occupée par l'armée américaine ou encore
l'emblématique gare et le château de
rambouillet tout en respectant les
règles sanitaires actuellement nous
avons des jauges encore très limité donc
aujourd'hui ces neuf personnes plus le
guide conférencier donc effectivement il
fallait réserver le masque est
obligatoire pour le public et après la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire on va
remonter un petit peu la jauge mais la
réservation restera prudente un des
visites tout public sur réservation qui
ont commencé en juillet et se
termineront en septembre pour les
prochaines déambulation les habitants
pourront découvrir rambouillet en tant
que ville impériale ou encore
rambouillet autant des présidents et
puis pour refermer ce journal une
question avez vous déjà entendu parler
du bière tourisme c'est une façon de
découvrir sa région par le travail du
houblon à maryland à pishin haussier est
essayée dans les yvelines avec nicolas
d'andry manon varaldo et mathilde et
demi les brasseries artisanales sont en
pleine expansion
en ile-de-france il en existe plus de 90
et le syndicat des brasseurs de france
s'attelle à développer le tourisme
brassicole avec la création d'un site
internet sur lequel on retrouve une
carte interactive des brasseries
alors j'ai cherché et comptabilisé une
douzaine de brasserie dans les yvelines
de quoi se faire un vrai circuit partons
à la découverte du département à travers
ces artisans de la transformation du
houblon
[Musique]
première découverte aux portes de la
plaine de versailles la brasserie au
club de bois d'arcy propose des billets
en barriques sébastien va nous raconter
tout ça o clock existe depuis 2015 et
deux ans après sa création la bande de
copains a voulu tester le vieillissement
des bières en barriques des barriques
qui ont déjà servi pour du whisky du
sauternes du cognac et autres spiritueux
et qui peuvent transmettre leur histoire
en résulte la gamme baden power nous ce
qui nous plaît énormément là dedans
c'est c'est cette espèce d'effet
surprise c'est dès le jour de la
livraison et même le jour de la commande
c'est à dire qu'on va appeler la
tonnellerie
on leur dit qu est-ce que vous avez des
dispenses moment et nous envoie une
liste et puis on va choisir un peu au
hasard parfois ce qui ce qu'ils ont et
le jour de la livraison c'est ouvrir les
bouchons mettre le nez dedans et se dire
ouais c'est ça ça va être génial
aujourd'hui la brasserie dispose d'une
cinquantaine de barrick dans lesquelles
les pierres vieillissent entre 6 et 18
mois
dernière cuvée la you really is une
collaboration avec une brasserie russe
une bière à 13° vieilli dans une
barrique de cognac avec des copeaux de
noix de coco torréfié
[Musique]
pour notre arrêt en vallée de chevreuse
nous sommes plus précisément au
perray-en-yvelines pour découvrir la
brasserie de la vallée de chevreuse
elle compte une gamme d'une douzaine de
bières et parmi elles des bières bio
d'abord installée à bonnel emmanuel est
l'un des premiers à s'être lancée dans
les yvelines en 2008 une première année
en bière conventionnel avant de passer
au bio
je me suis laissé convaincre par un
copain tout simplement qui pour lui
toute sa démarche vers le bio était
tournée vers les générations futures
alors on en pense qu'on en veut mais
c'était c'était sa démarche et
après peu après cette discussion il a eu
des jumeaux et donc samassa va un petit
peu fait réfléchir et après j'ai
converti la bière en bio la vol céleste
à ses consommateurs réguliers la
brasserie a déménagé de bonnet lo
perray-en-yvelines il ya deux ans pour
s'agrandir de 200 elle est passée à 2000
mètres carrés
[Musique]
très réactif chez tout ça ils ont su
trouver la solution pour ne pas perdre
le stock des fûts destinés au bar la
brasserie prépare dès janvier février
ses stocks pour l'été on s'est dit qu'il
serait difficile de passer ses fûts avec
le confinement parce qu'on connaissait
pas la date la date de fin et du coup
est venue l'idée de ces petits fûts qui
nous permettait de transvaser les fugues
de bach amphi 2 5 litres utilisable par
le grand public
ces petits fûts connaissent un tel
succès qu'ils vont rester parmi les
produits proposés brasserie tout ça a
été créé en 2016 dans un esprit familial
avant d'avoir sa ligne d'embouteillage
ce sont les propres parents de clément
qui s'en charge et à la main aujourd'hui
c'est bien on même une place de choix
dans la cave spécialisé en vins naturels
de son grand frère
notre parcours de bière tourisme dans
les ive et une s'achève et c'est alors
bien sûr tout ceci est à consommer avec
modération mais on peut pas s'empêcher
de terminer tout ça avec une petite
dégustation et les yvelines ne manque
d'ailleurs pas de ressources pour vous
occuper durant l'été mélanie poker vous
propose d'ailleurs un 7,8 loisirs
spéciale était un concentré d'animation
d'activités et de sorties pour passer
ses vacances dans le département
une émission à voir ou revoir sur tv 78
notre application mobile ou encore nos
différents réseaux sociaux
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]